an epic flood dynamic weather systems
character voice lines and the return of
the seven let's talk about fortnight
season 3 hello and welcome to
Playstation grenade it's the best part
of the season the live event approaches
and the leaks and rumors begin to land
about the new season but before we break
down everything we have a tradition to
keep every season there's a comedy skin
in the battle pass we've had a tomato
headed vampire under James Bond banana
but now can you guess what it'll be in
season 3 my money is on a Sponge Bob
Squarepants crossover see you but down
for 10 minutes slap cold atom arrow in
the star to support this content and
let's go through 14 season three leaks
and insane theories let's start with
what we think we know I'm sure you've
heard the flood theory by now
over the last few weeks the storm
circles the clouds in the sky and the
rivers have been acting rather strangely
on top of that the return of the no
sweat insurance company which
specialises in protecting against
natural disasters by throwing these two
theories together we come to the
conclusion a flood theme is inevitable
for season three and yeah Sony have even
accidentally leaked the icon for the new
season
definitely a flood and fortnight also
has a habit of foreshadowing future
content in live events during the Travis
Scott concert we all swam around letting
epic test their new mechanics on an
audience who didn't know what was going
on
clever guys the thing which I questioned
right now though is how do we breathe
underwater at present we drown but let's
just put a pin in that for the time
being
basically it's hard to refute a flood is
coming but let's add to this remember a
few seasons ago I suggested elemental
effects would come to butter Royale in
season eight fire ice that kind of thing
well I was sorta right a volcano
destroyed structures which is fire
damage well now in season three of
chapter two this premonition is gaining
traction
a mysterious leaker reached out to a
youtuber named
who with more leaks suggesting that fire
damage is not only back but it's dynamic
and environmental meaning everywhere a
fire starts it will continue spreading
until the entire building or structure
is ablaze what a change that could be
and yet again this is being tested in
game at the petrol and gas stations and
Tina's gas canisters to think about how
great it would be to burn down someone
who's cranking nineties and once again
this was in Travis Scott's event hiding
in plain sight with fireballs and
burning rollercoasters other things that
could return with this fire damage is
the LTM the floor is lava I honestly
cannot wait to play that with my
community it's gonna be lit yeah you're
here for their dad jokes so I decided to
go down the elemental damage effects and
link that with the weather machine
we're expecting Midas to reveal at the
agency and I think we have one of the
greatest rumors and potential leaks ever
instead of us being responsible for
burning down structures nature could do
this we already have lightning bolts in
game do you remember how Kevin the cube
began life could we see lightning hit
trees or buildings and caused them to
burn from what I've witnessed epic and
mimicking what made them so successful
in chapter 1 for example there wasn't a
live event in the first season and in
season 3 meteors began to fall and
impact battles suddenly lightning
strikes causing fire doesn't seem so
far-fetched and heck yes I'm going to
continue with this I think we will see
dynamic weather changes in fortnight we
already have a structured day/night
cycle in game but not dynamic weather
could Midas's device change everything
we know and spark freak weather affects
the idea of everything being flooded is
quite entertaining but honestly would
you want that for four months I doubt it
so what if the floods are only one part
of this like I said lightning bolts
could return but check this look at the
rivers in game right now the water
levels rise and then quickly lower again
this could be the same for the flood for
example in one game the water could be
extremely deep and then in another it
could be a drought all the water could
have dry
up the next game it may be raining with
those bolts of lightning and the damage
they caused in the next game the weather
could be so hot our builds burned down
in 30 seconds so there is so much
potential to create El TMS around the
weather and it looks like I'm not the
only person to notice this
[Music]
reddit user William Bosch made mock-up
images of all the elemental weather
changes that could impact the island
some of these are brilliant Eva as an LT
mm or in the BR moat rain and fog to
change visibility and sound lightning
which destroys everything on a tile
kinda like the burning effects but more
instantaneous a storm tornado which
completely destroys a Pio eye and the
sandstorm which again has been hinted at
in previous updates and currently can be
found in save the world think of all the
things that this could bring back to
remember the takos falling from the sky
in season X all the stars up at the
suburbs so much potential
please make this rumor a reality epic
but to be honest I just want to play the
floor is lava again pretty please
so let's go back to the event this
weekend intriguingly named the device I
decided to research if those words had
been used in the game before and found
this
I didn't factor is that the only way to
trigger the device was from within the
loop itself back in season X the
visitors recordings told us about a
device before back then the device was
something used by the seven remember
them the intergalactic group who broke
us away from the singularity loop in
Chapter one could the device in Chapter
two be the return of the seven could -
be one of the seven hence why he doesn't
divulge his plan or a better theory
could the engineer the girl in the
photograph be one of the seven so far
this chapter only a single woodcarving
has told us about the identity of the
seven and only three have been revealed
thus far we'll know more once the device
is activated so remember to come back
I'll try and find all the secrets for
that also here's another thing I noticed
whilst researching this the visitor say
something else listen again when you
hear this again remember once loops will
I be just as muted as the others the
visitor directly tells us that
characters have been muted up to this
point
whereas in Chapter two some characters
can speak okay it's not really speaking
it's well hear for yourself if you play
save the world you already know the
voices of many of the characters
including penny
garbage rats there's structural damage
per penny could we see voice lines added
to fortnight epic I'd really like to be
a voice character please I need to find
a purpose for my worthless life also
this would make battle passes completely
unmissable to unlock new voice lines for
your favorite characters
let's get back to the leaks as many
people are guessing the chances of an
Aquaman crossover are pretty strong and
many people are suggesting sharks will
be a new vehicle in the new season I
don't have any proof of that so here's
my glider I knew it would come in handy
one day
well the thing I'm struggling to
understand is how can we swim underwater
and stay alive have you tried it
currently if we stay submerged too long
we pop our clogs
well gaming history has taught us that
bubbles could be a way to survive
underwater and with the leakers
proclaiming Aquaman is coming what about
a mermaid ability or a male one what the
hell do you column male mermaid Merman
murmur dude yeah it's definitely
murdered a perfect middle ground between
swimming with your legs and riding a
shark another thing coming from the
tabor hill leaks are the quick change
booth staying in the game for skin
changes mid-match well what if these
gave us a scuba gear for underwater
shenanigans it would keep the mechanics
relatively based in real life of course
everything I've talked about needs to be
proven which nobody has done just yet
but the clues are always in the battle
pass let's quickly check it and note the
following tiers at tier 19 the image
shows rain and lightning backing up our
theory about dynamic weather changes at
tier 41 a rainbow can be seen
foreshadowing the phenomenon when
certain weather patterns change rapidly
and that tier 65 we see fire damage has
burnt down the farmland this could be
via the event on Saturday or this could
show how environmental flames will work
at tier 27 the circular clouds appearing
above the agency can be seen and that
tier 73 there's a scuba diver
foreshadowing our ability to swim
underwater all the clues were here from
day one my mind is blown I may be in
love with you epic games by the way I
use coded amaru when you grab the next
battle pass thanks dudes
the new season leaks have also confirmed
new weapons like a rocket to take out
those choppers how great would that be
it's also not worthy that the
remote-controlled rocket is once again
on the table other weapons hinted at
include the flare gun do you remember
seeing that a few seasons back and many
have suggested that this
damage could be a result of that flagon
here's a weird story but I feel like now
is the best time to tell it in April
last year I was lucky enough to go to
the borderlands 3 reveal there were many
epic employees there and I chatted with
as many as I could I don't know if they
were developers of management or they
just made the tea to be honest but one
conversation thinking back now could be
related to season 3 a group of us were
chatting about weapons and the
opportunity to bring melee weapons from
save the world well one of those guys
talked about an underwater harpoon more
like a trident
back then I thought nothing of this but
now now I'm thinking he may have leaked
the future a year before it happened
what do you think a trident in fortnight
could be possible whilst we're on the
underwater groove there are a few things
we should remember in the water around
the current map for example truckasaurus
remains in the sea he hasn't moved since
the first day of chapter 2 there's an
upturned boat in the shallow water
around the island and there's lots of
these underwater faces to discover but I
was thinking about chapter 1 do you
remember when this happened in the final
battle the Polar Peak monster ripped off
the mechs arm and spat it into the sea
if we're going underwater in chapter 3
let's try and find where this relic of
yesteryear is hopefully it came through
the black hole with us fingers crossed
another thing we spoke of in chapter 1
was the ability to create our own sprays
and customize how we look then a season
later Donald mustard the creative
director of Epic Games told us about the
importance of player agency and those
players dictating the changes in the
game well these theories came together
in chapter 2 to create my ax a one-time
character completely unique to you the
player so it's safe to say next season
we have another opportunity to do this
maybe creating a glider or an umbrella
or a weapon wrap or maybe just maybe we
can create our own sprays it's
technically already happening with the
recent competition epic held the issue
will always be though if we give
everyone this design opportunity will
they will they create something which is
a non PG like a hairy rocket ship or a
couple of melons it's safe to say him
for customization is coming too far
tonight and I'll play a choice to
deciding what
pants to the island the strongest choice
right now is to let us customize our own
umbrellas
[Music]
remember back when apex legends arrived
and epic were quick to add reboot vans
to fortnight and the tagging system -
yeah some people call that stealing
other people call that incorporating
ideas I'll let you decide which is which
the main thing I wanted to note though
was that warzone has a really cool
mechanic called the Gulag I'm sure
you've seen all the memes about it could
we see fortnight add this to their game
after being eliminated in the game you
take part in a one-on-one competition
for the chance to redeploy into the
match it is pretty fun but epic could
change this for example they could make
it a race to a rift whoever gets there
first survives whoever doesn't is out of
the game
they could be minigames just little
things to change the flow of the game
and make being eliminated a little less
stressful what do you think is safe to
say fortnight is here to stay every
competitor has fallen away over the last
three years and fortnight aren't resting
on their laurels the party royale mode
came out it's a great inclusion and
hopefully next season save the world
will once again get its story content
which ties in everything that happens on
battle royale Island we all need to know
about penny and one day get her into
battle royale the queen of thick needs
to be set free but in all seriousness
epic have hinted multiple times that
they are growing fortnight into more
than just battle royale and I'm all for
that I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
all the best for the event this Saturday
thank you so much for watching until
this point if you're still here I hope
he's still here and thanks to all these
people on screen now they've used my
code over the last week if you're not
there don't worry you'll be here on
Wednesday thanks again for your time see
ya
[Music]